qu'est-ce qu'on va pas refaire comme
vidé aujourd'hui [ __ ] j'ai pas d'idée
ah qu'est ce que les gens vont le voir
qu'est ce qu'ils feraient des buts non
non je ne ferai pas aimer l'eau de mer
sur ce jeu comme tous les youtube heures
parce que ça fait des vues je refuse de
rentrer dans ce système non mais quel
est ce jeu là ok 1 journée sur le jeu le
plus on veut rêver de tous les torts aya
sol natal freddy c'est le 26e au plus je
crois bon allez allez allez cesse de
tricky t on va faire de belles parties
aussi nouveau comment s'appelle
jean-michel je peux rien marqué un recul
et tu vois bien que ça bouge
oui et non c'était jean michel moulin va
pas commencer à me saouler et si tu
cours tu m'appeler à chaque début niveau
je me désabonne la chaîne youtube nuit
une allez c'est parti
d'accord donc à gauche à une meuf qui
danse des fois ils dansent pas faux que
j'appuie là pour les orienter les trop
chaud pour qu'elles se mettent à danser
et là on passe donc à la vitre de droit
qu'est ce qu'un autre côté rien hélas
pas riche plus rien de recettes pour
qu'ils soient là toi c'est quoi ça oui
ok c'est ce conduit qui nous ramène
d'une pierre qui nous passent d'une
cassano d'accord ok mais non on va se
faire choper dans conduits comme des
merdes vous pouvez pas faire un couloir
sinon normal on peut courir dehors
et perd sa forme est un électrochoc
il est à temps il est où le bébé
l'attachement pas vous voyez le bébé
doté de lavit ya rien n'est à eux
allez faut retourner dans l'autre pièce
est la première du avoir commencé à la
reine d'egypte
ce que je sais moi ok on est humble m ok
nous ajustons arrivé je sais plus je
sais plus bon ça chez lui c'est à cela
que nous amène au travail en fait du
coup on dirait une sorte de pizzerias
mais un peu cabaret qu il ya des
danseurs des trucs c'est des robots et
nous on doit les faire danser etc
en journée le technicien côté là dans
nos tuyaux avec des câbles comme ça et
il faut que tout le monde danse j'adore
cette musique elle est trop bien je vais
version longue so funny story
on sait très bien que l'histoire est
vraie et bientôt un corps va être
retrouvé mort sur cette chaise à est ce
qu'elle est en train de danser
eh bien non c'est vrai mais là on voit
des gros coup dur pour qui danse alors
foxy il est là il est prêt ce procès
allez on y va à la pièce d'en face ont
vérifié le bébé que des rejets pas
réussir à trouver à travers la vitre
batta il me laisse totalement dans le
noir quoi comme une vieille bits et un
truc est un truc j'ai entendu des bruits
de la ventilation
peu d'études pour payer mon loyer c'est
tout un pays en deux états sans contact
superbe à bercy s'est fait rassurant
[ __ ] d'un trou de jouets mega longuet
on est déjà à 70 minutes de vidéo under
the dusk gravir ok je en train de fermer
un truc et il ya des trous dedans et
donc je pense qu'il faut que j'évite
l'oeil c'est ça va piquer il arrive
bon c'est bon il ya plus personne je
peux y aller j'ai perdu l'habitude des
jeux noir je chiale à chaque fois été
pris pour prix nobel quoi la presse au
froid sous pression
game over
alors là faut m'expliquer bon ben voilà
on va passer en mode binaire
là on va passer en mode vénère allait
faire moi cette [ __ ] de portes de
merde on va trouver l'endroit n'y a pas
de trou et des qui va faire chier avec
un piolet là on va prendre la porte
on va la retenir comme ça ensuite on le
retrouve plein coup de couteau l'armé
voilà nous entraîner oh merde j'ai plus
le son peut pas savoir qu elle ouvre la
porte et c'est d'ouvrir mon gars tu y
arriveras pas et c'est d'ouvrir et c'est
vrai
vas-y open le nord open de dents au non
non non go arrête je peux pas faire
mieux là arrête comme ça le bébé n'a
plus de force que moi à temps il ya des
ratés qui particulier pour tenir cette
porte à les ouvrir aux ouvrages tu
attends mon gars n'ont pas volé sa
marche plus comme ça en fait faut juste
cliquer et rester avec la main fermée
sur la poignée bon je sais mais celui
qui sait pas il sait pas dire une porte
plus tu as trop compliqué c'est beau et
c'est pareil [ __ ] ok à trois conduits
en fait un deux trois ans avec le tuto
ici l'on sait qu'un mille fois plus
d'éléments kabango bordel c'est quoi ça
deux techniques push mais qu'est ce que
je dois faire
d'accord
oh j'en ai marre c'est juste du
skimboard gratuit ce jeu est signalé par
toi il ya la musique là si je bouge à la
barre tout est là c'est quoi ça à
l'olive à cette partie allez allez on y
croit
je fais quoi
je fais quoi tâche et je suis vraiment
nul je n'arrive pas à comprendre la
logique là et là ya pas de musique la
musique arrive là elle est là je
m'arrête
tu peux y aller
bon allez on va écouter les gens comme
prévu j'ai apprécié pas trop ce jeu par
contre j'avoue il a complètement changé
le gameplay et ça je trouve ça vraiment
cool maintenant il suffit plus juste de
checker des caméras comme ça et fermer
une porte quand le monstre est là c'est
beaucoup plus complexe à beaucoup plus
d'éléments et des nouvelles mécaniques
trouve ça cool
après j'avoue ça me ça me fait pas qu'y
fait à mort va écouter si vous avez
6,079 a dépensé alesi et puis dites moi
si vous avez qui fait les gens
apparemment carrément qui fait sur steam
et ça m'étonne pas parce que c'est bien
foutu mais voilà ce pas mon délire merci
d'avoir regardé n'était pas le dos à
vous a quand même plus je pars contre
l'escrimeur on les supporte plus du tout
c'est là on arrive à un stade où on peut
plus et la vieillesse on vieillit on se
fait vieux et notre petit coeur est
sensible à la tête deux prochaines
années dont mersenne regard des parties